I'm raising Sally I moderated the
session on opening borders building
trade propensity for emerging economies
we discussed three main issues first the
WTO and finishing the dough around
second or so for noodle bowl of free
trade agreements FTAs in East Asia and
third supply chains and making trade
easier facilitating it through these
regional and global supply chains on the
WTO front Pascal Lamy and other
ministers highlighted the costs of not
finishing the Doha round and perhaps the
biggest cost would be that it might
actually compromise domestic reforms
that are very necessary the domestic
trade reforms that are very necessary go
on outside the WTO but that would be
more difficult to achieve without
finishing the door Iraq as well we go
around itself members need to be more
modest and realistic perhaps have an
early harvest package for least
developed countries and they or maybe
one or two other things like trade
facilitation and bits of Agriculture and
finally the ASEAN contracts among other
middle powers wouldn't play a role in
actually using their good offices to
bring the big pieces like the Americans
and the Chinese and the Indians and
resilience together to them keep the
round on earth FTAs what was striking in
the discussion was that there was not
that much mention of tariffs which often
grab the headlines much more about all
the regulatory differences between the
FTAs which can create a very messy
noodle bowl and increase costs for
businesses so the challenge here is to
actually harmonize different standards
and iron out these differences between
ft 8 in order to make the supply chain
work and expand them throughout
throughout the region and the key thing
here is supply chains in East Asia need
to be expanded beyond ICT into other
parts of manufacturing and services and
indeed agriculture and that involves not
just headline free policy reforms but
also a lot of domestic reforms to
improve the business climate over